Speaker 1: If you thought we had finally heard the
last of failed Arizona gubernatorial Republican
candidate Carrie Lake, you were wrong. She is
continuing to make all sorts of outlandish claims
about the things she's going to do to, I guess,
try to steal an election. She lost to Katie Hobbs,
whose election win has been certified
and who listen very carefully here
will be the governor of Arizona. Katie Hobbs will
be the governor of Arizona. Carrie Lake will not
be the governor of Arizona because Katie Hobbs got
more votes. And that's the way the system works.
That's a good thing if the person who got the
fewest votes became the governor. That would be
a real problem. Carrie Lake seems, I guess, to
have found an ally in Stephen Bannon. And here
is Steve Bannon visibly struggling to cope with
Carrie Lake's loss. And he's struggling so badly,
he starts making up words.
Speaker 2: If she had the
receipts to show that she was legitimate,
she would come forth and answer all this.
All they're doing is obfuscating.
Speaker 1: Obfuscating. Careful,
careful, careful. Obfuscating.
Speaker 2: The reason is they
ain't got the receipts. That's right. I
understand that this election was stolen.
Let me underline that. Five times stolen.
Speaker 1: This really misunderstands burden
of proof. And this is a real classic from the
right. They did this with 2020 as well. Well,
we've got all these suspicious things
that happened. Prove Joe Biden really won.
That's the wrong burden of proof. Katie Hobbs got
more votes and won. No one has brought forward a
bona fide, legitimate challenge to that. Why does
Katie Hobbs now need to do anything? The election
is over. The votes were counted. Carrie Lake and
Steve Bannon and Trump and their cronies haven't
been able to demonstrate that the person who won
it didn't really win. Katie Hobbs doesn't have
to present anything to them. And this this is a
regular thing that they do a flip the burden of
proof. Here's Kerry Lake now defiant. They're
not going to keep stealing elections. Well,
they haven't stolen any any Kerry.
Speaker 2: If they think they can
continue to steal and rig elections, they are
messing with the wrong people because they don't.
Speaker 1: Think that they haven't done it.
Speaker 2: It'll stand up right now, Steve,
and fight for this at this moment. I
know people are tired, but this is the
moment we need to get into the fight. Right?
Because if we let them rig another election,
it's game over. It's the country's.
Speaker 1: Let's not let them rig any
more elections. I mean, they haven't rigged any.
So that's a good track record. And let's make
sure that they don't start. These folks are
completely delusional. Here is just one more
clip. Just. It's. It's. It's opium. My friends.
Speaker 2: Kerry Lake, who is let me be blunt.
When you look at the analysis, you
look at the data, you look at this
lawsuit is the governor elect of Arizona.
Speaker 1: She is not the governor elect of
Arizona. She lost. Do you think Steve Bannon
believes this crap for a second? I have a
really hard time believing that he does.
Speaker 2: There's just no doubt she won
this election. And they've circled
the wagons to protect Katie Hobbs.
And this is going to be a battle royale.
Speaker 1: Because if there's going to be no
battle, the election's been certified for Katie
Hobbs. Katie Hobbs will be the governor there.
There's no battle other than in their minds.
Speaker 2: You're if you're in for a penny,
you got to be in for a pound here on
this fight. Right in the fight is in
Arizona and the fight is in Arizona today.
Speaker 1: Yeah, there's no fight. I mean,
yes, they are submitting what they claim to be
legal complaints and maybe some qualify as legal
complaints. There is no fight in so far as Katie
Hobbs will be sworn. I mean, I hate to even say it
unless she's dead. Katie Hobbs will be sworn in as
the governor and that's it. That's the end of it.